good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight one of the Hallmarks of
people who were telling the truth in
case you were wondering how to tell the
difference is that people who are
telling the truth are calm they don't
wave their hands around and make wild
accusations they don't need to do that
it's enough to say what they know and if
honest people turn out to be wrong about
something they have claimed they'll
admit it they don't double down on false
they made a mistake and that's okay it's
not like they're claiming to be God
Liars behave differently Liars are
touchy sometimes to the point of
Hysteria they're hiding something that's
the whole point of lying and their word
you're going to find out what it is
Liars are fragile because over time
lying makes you weak and afraid it has
the same effect on countries by the way
we're living through one of those
clarifying moments actually we're
thankful for where we're learning
exactly who the Liars are on Monday we
showed you unreleased videotape from
January 6th it proved that tape proved
that three of the most important claims
our leaders have made about that day
were untrue their claims were lies
we were not shocked to discover that we
knew there was a reason that
Congressional leaders had been hiding
the tape and that reporters in
Washington weren't demanding to see it
they were lying to us obviously that's
why you hide things
but what was actually surprising when we
can't quite get over even now is how
they responded when they were caught
lying they didn't seem embarrassed they
didn't apologize they weren't even
curious to learn more about what
actually happened on January 6th let's
see the tape no they didn't want to see
it they exploded in Rage and then as
Liars tend to do they doubled down
they told the same lies they've been
caught telling but with even greater
aggression this time shut up it's
midnight they said as the sun rose
behind them
who acts like that well sociopaths do
and in this case the sociopaths turned
out to be both Democrats and Republicans
the commitment to lying in Washington is
far deeper and more bipartisan even than
we realized we follow the stuff for a
living
now you sometimes hear people say the
whole partisan system is an illusion and
that underneath the manufactured debates
the leaders on both sides are in fact
secretly United in a common love of
money and power and the deception
required to get them
and honestly we could never really bring
ourselves to believe that it's just too
dark
but now we do believe it because we have
seen it
consider the death of police officer
Brian sicknick now we still don't know
exactly how officer sicknick died we're
not certain that anyone does know no one
has explained it
but after reviewing the previously
withheld video evidence we can tell you
with certainty that officer schicknick
was not beaten to death by Trump voters
at the Capitol the tape shows very
clearly Brian sicknick walking through
the building in apparent Health after
the media told us for two years that he
had been murdered
so they were wrong about that okay they
got caught here's the interesting thing
they won't admit it Liz Cheney's tweet
is still on Twitter tonight officer
shiknik was killed defending our capital
from the violent mob on January 6th no
correction Anderson Cooper of CNN still
has not apologized quote officer Brian
sicknick died after being hit in the
head with a fire extinguisher during the
fight he told us those are lies
so why not just admit it and move on but
they won't
in fact this week the White House
trotted out both the press secretary and
Joe Biden's attorney general the
Attorney General of the United States to
claim not just that Brian signic was
actually murdered by Republicans at the
Capitol but that other officers were
murdered too
it's it's almost beyond belief watch
this
the Rye Rage of bipartisan lawmakers you
heard them all yesterday you guys
reported on it who have condemned uh
this false depiction of the
unprecedented violent attack on cons on
our Constitution and the rule of law
which caused police police officers
their lives it was a violent attack on a
fundamental tendent of American
democracy that power is peacefully
transferred from one Administration to
another uh
over a hundred officers were assaulted
on that day five officers died
five officers died on that day
that's just not some guy on Twitter
that's the Attorney General of the
United States that's a man whose honesty
is Central to his job if he had a choice
between IQ and integrity in an attorney
general of course you would go with
Integrity because it's essential
but Joe Biden's attorney general Merrick
Garland is a liar he just lied about
something that is provably false who are
these five officers who were quote
killed that day
notice he didn't tell you no one ever
tells you no one ever shows you their
autopsies they don't want any detail
they just want the slogan now they're
counting Brian sicknick that's a lie
but who are the other four well those
are four officers who killed themselves
after January 6 in some cases long after
January 6th but there are suicides we
know for a fact
were the result of the Republican mob at
the Capitol it's just it's just false
and it's not some esoteric fact that
fact is available to anyone who has
internet access no police officers died
that day on January 6th none not one
some were assaulted that is true and
their assaults are indefensible so how
many were assaulted
well Garland said over a hundred the
government accountability office says
the number is 114. we're just going to
roll with that we don't know if it's
true but we'll take it to face value and
that is bad we are opposed to assaulting
police officers in any context we said
that on January 6 2020 almost say it
again we're against that
but is January 6th the worst assault on
the US government since the Civil War
that's insane it's not even close how
about March of 1954 when Puerto Rican
separate has shot five congressmen in
the Capitol building five members of
Congress shot in the building
it's all bad but the worst since the
Civil War years to flat out liar if
you're saying that
more recently this is an event we all
remember antifa descended on Washington
DC to force the sitting president from
office but it was Trump so that's cool
and while they were there they set a
historic Christian church on fire St
John's in Lafayette Square do you
remember that
you should because it happened Labor Day
weekend less than three years ago and
when it happened the left-wing mayor of
Washington DC refused to allow her
Police Department the MPD to assist
Secret Service agents while they were
under siege and getting beaten no she
made her COPS stand back and watch it
happen and they were very upset about it
at the time you may have forgotten that
here's what it looked like
[Music]
[Applause]
I believe there are several fires raging
now down this street and this is what
you hate to see there are people
throwing fireworks and who knows what
else
[Applause]
and that crane
is just fully engulfed
it's bad they just set fire to St John's
Church
[Applause]
[Music]
that is burning a church across from the
White House
those are the George Floyd riots
so what was the toll there now we're not
going to guess we're going to go again
right to the government according to
recently released GAO report last month
during those attacks the 2020 attack on
the White House by left-wing mobs were
quoting Federal Protective Services the
Secret Service and the Park police
reported that at least a hundred and
eighty officers were injured during the
demonstrations including concussions
lacerations exposure to chemical gas and
severe burning
so while stipulating that all riots are
bad because Precision matters facts
matter the truth matters here's the
truth
more cops were injured by Kamala
Harris's favorite mob BLM at the White
House
then were injured by Trump voters at the
Capitol on January 6th a lot more so
again to be clear both events are bad
but here's the key we only remember one
of them why because the people in charge
of History are liars
liars and lying is bad and on a national
scale it's deadly it's corrosive of
everything that is good in the country
including trust and your grasp on
reality itself and that's why they try
to make you lie men can become women
climate change is an existential threat
or whatever the LIE is they're making
you tell they don't believe it they know
you don't believe it but by forcing you
to repeat it they degrade and control
you they make you less
of a person
they also hurt individuals we told you
Monday about Navy veteran Jacob
Chancellor he was Tried by the media
convicted of being a domestic terrorist
and sentenced to four years in prison
what exactly was Jacob chancellory's
crime well no one was ever very precise
about that here's what the media told
you it was
in his horned helmet fur pelts and face
paint Jacob chansley became known as the
Q Anon Shaman but prosecutors called him
the most prominent symbol of a violent
Insurrection he's been in jail since
January and he's trying to get out but
prosecutors say he is still too
dangerous to release make no mistake
Chelsea is a stone cold Thug he kept
saying I'm you know I'm not violent I'm
peaceful I'm a shaman but then you put
those images what you were just talking
about you put those images together and
that isn't an image of you know of Peace
this is the new face of extremism
it's a new face of extremism Jacob
chansley is the new face of extreme
extremism he's a stone cold Thug
prosecutors say he is too dangerous to
release and most people believe that
because why wouldn't they they were told
it and there was no evidence to the
contrary another is evidence the country
we brought it to you Monday
the video that we reviewed at Great
length over three weeks showed with
Precision what Jacob chansley actually
did inside the capital and here's what
it looks like once again
here's video of chansley in the Senate
chamber Capitol police officers take him
to multiple entrances and even try to
open lock doors for him we counted at
least nine officers who were within
touching distance of unarmed Jacob
chansley not one of them even tried to
slow him down
Chancellor understood that Capitol
Police were his allies video shows him
giving thanks for them in a prayer on
the floor of the Senate watch
foreign
contrast the reality of what Jacob
chansley did in the Capitol building on
January 6th the indisputable facts
recorded on video some of which has
never before been seen with the
depiction of Jacob chansley that you've
seen in the media for more than two
years he's a terrorist they said he
should be killed shoot him shoot him
like if it you burst into the United
States hey if he was dressed like Bin
Laden would have shot him shoot him
shoot him
it makes you wonder who are the violent
extremists here
so as you saw and again Details Matter
because this is a man this is an
American citizen a Navy veteran this is
a human being and so what he actually
did should be of deep concern to every
American because he's in jail tonight
what Jacob chancelly actually did was
wander peacefully through the capital
shepherded by Capital police officers
who literally opened doors for him when
one was locked they went to another
dozens of officers stood and watched him
all of them had guns Jacob chancely did
not they never told Jacob chancy to get
out
the head of the Capitol Police today
said he was trying to calm the situation
it was already come
he was the only protester in the frame
they could have let him outside they
didn't they helped him we're not going
to speculate as to why we don't know why
all we know is what we see on the tape
and no one disputes it we didn't cherry
pick it we didn't make it up
once inside the Senate chamber as we
told you Chelsea said a prayer thanking
God for the kindness of Capitol Hill
Police
and good for him they were kind this was
not a domestic terrorist
and that matters
but what matters even more is the videos
that we showed you after 26 months were
not shown to Jacob chansley's attorneys
that's a violation of the Constitution
and he's in jail because of it because
the Liars on the January 6 committee and
the prosecutors who did their bidding
and that means Benny Thompson and that
means Adam Schiff it means Liz Cheney
these people have this man's life on
their hands
they helped withhold these videos from
Jacob chansley's attorneys
and that means the judge who sentenced
Jacob chancelly Royce Lamberth never saw
them either
and therefore Lambert was able to say
judge Lambeth was able to say that what
chansley did was quote horrific
he apparently had no idea the chance he
was wandering around with the cops
walking through doors they opened and
saying prayers for them
we're quoting you made yourself the
center of the riot said the judge really
he accused chansley of quote obstruction
obstructing the functioning of
government
but that's not all what was happening he
was ambling through the capital flight
at all times by armed cops or directing
his movement
meanwhile prosecutors of the DHA the
real villains here falsely they lied in
court and said that chansley was quote
leading the charge into the capital on
January 6th
they said he was quote the flag bearer
for the mob apparently because he had a
flag he was alone
and of course the media picked up on
this and Amplified it as the doj
intended
Fortune Magazine disgraced Itself by
comparing the man you just saw to Isis
they said Chancellor had quote the Zeal
to possibly kidnap or kill officials
these aren't just lies these are lies
that destroyed a man
so no matter who you voted for in the
last election you could probably agree
that sending someone to prison for four
years on the basis of fabricated
evidence
is the most serious threat to civil
liberties we could possibly face
and yet here's the thing leaders in both
parties the party that Chancey voted
against and the party he voted for have
said nothing not one word about the
implications of this videotape the
implications not just for chansley but
for our Constitution and our country
going forward
instead oh how dare you show this
what is clearly exculpatory evidence and
again it's not just Chuck Schumer it's
Republican Senators Kevin Kramer Mike
rounds Chuck Grassley John thune Lindsey
Graham of course Congressman Dan
Crenshaw needless to say Kelly Armstrong
all went after us
we're not whining about that we don't
care actually but it just tells you
everything
about the way things actually work
they're not loyal to their voters
they're loyal to each other
and they're willing to lie really lie
and Crush people
Mitch McConnell Tom Tillerson BLM
superfan Mitt Romney all week men and
like all weak men vicious men were
especially angry watch
it was a mistake in my view for
Fox News to depict this
in a way that's completely at variance
with what our chief law enforcement
official here at Capitol thanks I think
it's both when you see police barricades
breached when you see police officers
assaulted all of that or you had to be
in close proximity to it if you were
just a tourist you should have probably
lined up at the visitor center and came
in on an orderly basis I just don't
think it's helpful it's really sad to
see Tucker Carlson go off the rails that
bad the American people saw what
happened on January 6th they've seen the
people that got injured they saw the
damage to the building
you can't hide the truth
by selectively picking a few minutes out
of tapes and saying this is what went on
it's it's so absurd
weak men are vicious men and these are
weak men whose attitudes towards an
individual whose life has been destroyed
on the basis of false and withheld
evidence is vicious
oh we Cherry Picked really what they're
saying
ironically what they're describing
ironically is exactly what the January 6
committee and the prosecutors in these
cases did for two years they selectively
picked small segments of tape to
convince Americans that January 6 was
something that it wasn't
it was awful we would not defend that we
hate vandalism we hate assault was it a
violent instruction it was not was it a
killing of five officers in the capital
it was not those are lies and they
buried tape they contradicted and
revealed those lies
so all we did was play the tape that
they had been hiding for 26 months and
show that there were American citizens
Jacob chansley specifically and others
whose civil liberties were annihilated
and you can make your own rational
judgments about what that means do you
want to live in a country where that's
possible
they don't care neither party in
Washington cares in fact the leader of
the Senate Democrats Chuck Schumer just
joined the leader of the Senate
Republicans Mitch McConnell in calling
for this show to be pulled off the air
now that's not an argument based on
logic it's based on hysteria and the
shame you feel
is a weak and terrified person when your
lies are exposed here's Chuck Schumer
claiming for the first time that like
Sandy Cortez he himself nearly died on
January 6th
Tucker Carlson ran a lengthy segment
last night arguing the January 6 Capital
attack was not not a violent
insurrection
an attempt to rewrite history in a road
the very Foundation
of our precious and sometimes fragile
democracy
so yes this morning I am furious
millions of Americans are Furious
I was here on January 6th
many of you saw the footage as I ran for
my life
coming within a few feet of these
criminals
yeah so we invited Schumer on McConnell
anybody is always welcome to come on our
show if we got something wrong tell us
how
if you think we altered the tape in some
way tell us how
but they won't nor they answer the most
basic question which is why should a
non-demonstrably non-violent man who
literally said a prayer of Thanksgiving
for police officers on the senate floor
how is that man Isis how was he a
domestic terrorist how is he a threat to
the Republic why is he in jail for four
years
shut up pull that show off the air
they won't answer any questions but we
have a question which is how in a free
country Guided by the Constitution were
these people allowed to withhold
evidence from Jacob chanslee's lawyer
how could that happen subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight